what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves another
trailer for The Mandalorian season three you
are looking at the crew today that will be
covering it on the channel we of course got
John John with all the knowledge John bring
it today every Easter eggs the force to
leave a like do that and of course we got
Michael Tessler who I've been covering the
bad batch season two with one of our most
knowledgeable Star Wars gentlemen I've ever
known I think that was a sentence I said how
are you Michael I'm so freaking excited uh
this season of the Mandalorian is gonna be
you think so I think so I mean it's it's like if
you watch the Clone Wars if you watched Rebels if
you watched any kind of or played any you know
Mandalorian adjacent content it's just gonna be
phenomenal looks like it's time I mean we gotta
go back to Mandalore all right guys let's do this
[Music] the people are scattered like stars
in the galaxy damn nice what do we stand for
I already have thoughts
not just learning about how to fight
you also have to know how to navigate the
Galaxy very true yeah you'll never be lost
I'm going to Mandalore so that I may
be forgiven for my transgressions whoa
Pele this is the way
there's something dangerous happening out
there whoa is that of course big
enough for you it'll be too late
OG helmet Whoa We did an order 66
flashback oh my God hang on kid
oh baby baby
I'm just coming back
this is the way this is the way oh dang
wow it looks okay yeah it could be better it
could be more exciting oh man that's a trailer
right there it looks like we're gonna see some
Order 66 flashback yeah probably explaining a
little bit more expanding upon the grogu yeah
which is so exciting to figure out how the heck
did little baby grogu make it all that time yeah
we saw some of that in season two didn't we oh we
saw a little bit but somebody had to help him true
true well I mean what I loved first off about this
trailer was just the very beginning of it is going
back to the heart of what is a Mandalorian today
because you got all these different divisions you
know if you think of it like a religion it's like
you got a bunch of different denominations of
mandalorians I mean even in the last season when
bocatan first met up with dinjarin she calls that
what his way of being a Mandalorian right which is
funny because then she part she was part of the
Night wall night owls which is Death Watch and
then death watches with saved dinjarin yeah that's
what I mean it's like the subsex and that's what
the beginning of this trailer was exploring the
topic of like Hey we're all divided right now yeah
and we're constantly having a goddamn Civil War
and now we need to find a way of of unity so it
seems like this will be the unity of mandalorians
I feel like it's going to be one of the coolest
expansions on Mandalorian culture because we're
going to see different kinds yet some type of way
of maybe the one look at some freaking Beast
for the first time ever maybe maybe or maybe
we'll have some more wart yeah because you know
what's better though it's called star piece it
was really cool to see Mandalore just like I mean
it was alluded to so many times the devastation
that was wrought it kind of reminded me when we
when we saw that Mandalorian helmet just kind of
covered in Ash and and rust uh of some of those
like Rebels episodes where the empire was testing
out ways to take on uh bescar armor you have so
much of what they developed during the Clone Wars
so much of what was developed even before that
with the Knights of the Old Republic it was just
nice seeing like little subtle Inspirations from
all those different parts of Star Wars lore just
kind of all coming to fruition and the season
I'm super jazzed I'm especially interested Bo
Katan where she's gonna land and where she's been
a little absent in these trailers well I think
I think it's because she might very well be our
antagonist I mean she would make a lot of sense to
be but I'm also like kind of on our side a little
bit I also just have to say like seeing the the
N1 uh starfighters even if you don't watch book
of boba for any other reason just for that life
episode was like there might be a lot of confused
people who didn't watch book of Boba Fett who were
like yeah wait a minute why are they back together
what what did Luke what was going on plus you know
he's also motivated to reclaim being an actual
Mandalorian as well so this one could be like
really big and epic and also probably the most
personal but yeah John yes what'd you think man
we got a side noobs we got uh no there's plenty
in here man no you're like with grief cargo like
I was he looks all Regal this time around well
yeah this trailer gave me two things it gave me a
thematic hope but it also just gave me that punch
of this felt like watching the trailer for like a
big Blockbuster sequel to something where it's
like okay the story is continuing but now we've
got even more of everything that was so cool about
the story up until this point and I think that if
they can combine all the beautiful world hopping
and the struggles of Mandalore with a theme I
think of Andor and they've done a really nice job
of exploring the political spectrum of Star Wars
and I feel like hear what you could do is in a
subtle way do a rumination on the struggles of
faith in a world like this because you guys were
talking about like the Mandalorian culture is so
spread out fractured and otherwise that I think
you can could do a lot of really interesting
stuff with that while also maintaining the nomadic
quality that the show has had this feels like it
will be maybe a slightly more serialized blend of
the episodic serial storytelling they like to do
here it certainly looks more consistent than the
book of books yeah I think that's something that
I I'm excited for is for the store to have just a
bit more Focus which I think it will definitively
have for this season but it's also easy to forget
that Mandalore is not the only Mandalorian Planet
you know we're talking about what is in essence
a small Empire in of itself and these various
factions that exist in these places there's so
much about this as it seems to be building up
to getting the development of the first order and
you and also the explanation of what a snoke is
but you see all the Snopes down in snokeville
Craig do you see Dr Pershing looks like he's
in Coruscant was that did I read the trailer
footage correctly that definitely struck me
as Coruscant or any kind of other major I
mean that has to be Coruscant yeah lighting
or I mean or they just overlapped his
lines do you want footage from course
but it looked like he was actually traveling
throughout Coruscant yeah which it should be
noted is is technically not the capital of
the new Republic uh which really noted but
I always kind of wondered you know because it
was it was rotating uh it ended up in hosnian
Prime at the time of the force awakens uh
and dweeb chandrilla why are you here yeah
it's exciting to see you know Coruscant didn't
necessarily really have a great run of it in
the days after the Empire what do you mean uh
you know just major urban center that you know
leaned heavily on an imperial police force
that suddenly disappeared at the end of the
war and an underfunded New Republic you know
which was putting all of its philosophy here
no I was going to say it looks fine unless
it's a flashback interesting point or this is
just a clip from Blade Runner you guys yeah
just slipped it in there first and foreign
I think because they showed that and then they
went to the flashback of what will look like
Order 66 yeah which is a nice I mean good to
establish that we're going to be spending some
time in the past I love that we can do that
through the lens of grogu too where it's not
just like oh we're just doing a flashback for
the sake of a flashback but it's as certain
things happen to grogu they have this Force
connection that allows them to to is that just
PTSD is that what I'm describing right now I think
so that's post-traumatic Force disorder well guys
um I thought this was an amazing trailer I can't
wait to cover this show we're all gonna have fun
yes sir sure are fun right sir have fun and uh
use the force to leave a like what did you guys
think about this trailer all right guys leave
your thoughts down below let's send this with a
Maria Hammond Maria in a lot of ways I like to
think I'm your baby grogu and you're my tin jar
sure just taking care of me and then John tell
you're like the second child you know you're
like you're like I'm like a Droid that you kick
around and you keep on hand just in case you're
like we have to take care but really you know I'm
gonna take all the credit sure and then Michael
you're you're like a Charming side character who
makes a big sacrifice leaves a big impression or
is just Panther yeah sure yeah that's true like I
don't really know about that Michael guy you keep
him around I'm a scruffy looking Nerf herder and
that's why they keep me around but Maria you have
graced us with your presence and so much physical
items as well but so much time and attention has
been given to us uh for such a long time now
and I'm excited to keep you in my life for at
least the remainder of 2023 sure we'll see how my
attitude changes and if you want to leave by 2024
but I'm hoping that for the remainder of time I'd
love to renew your contract if we can so yeah but
thank you for being such a such a sweetheart and
I love you dear hope I gotta reply to you I know
I got a message review on Twitter I gotta reply
to you and I'm a little late there but talk soon
foreign